thank you anna for the introduction and
sharing the session and thanks ryan
sanjin stephen anders you know for
organizing this session i'm really happy
to have this opportunity to report some
of our recent studies in my group
i'm talking about a few attempts we have
made for denoising a large um
from a
pharmacogenomic dataset
so let me
give a
brief introduction on the background
first and also how we got into this
field
we started we started this line of
research on
pharmacogenomic studies a few years ago
and the typical
pharmacogenomic studies involve you know
drugs tested against panels of
molecularly characterized cancer cell
lines so the typical data is involved
will be including drug response
measurements like the drug sensitivity
data
listed here so i will explain a little
bit more since that it's the major data
set we will work on and also gene
expression data and also other types of
molecular profiles and of the cancer
cell lines
the major goal of
pharma pharmacogenomic studies is to um
connect the drug response data with
molecular purpose of cancer cells
together you know to identify meaningful
biomarkers you know that can be
predictive of responses of cancer cells
you know to individual drugs
so the drug sensitivity data is kind of
the data we have been focusing on and
you can see that so the uh in the matrix
here so in this particular matrix so the
columns have here are drugs so they can
be fda approved or pre-proof the drugs
and the x-axis here are cancer cell
lines and they also have molecular
profiles you know associated with these
cell lines so the values here you know
they will be a summaries of uh drug
response a drug dose response curve so
basically drug with a varied doses will
be uh used to treat you know other
cancer cell lines and then there will be
a drug response curve produced and there
are different methods to summarize that
kind of curve you know to tell how
effective you know the drug is to treat
the cancer shell line or how the cancer
cell lines are responding you know to
the particular drug so there are like
auc area under the response curve and
there are also sc50 or some kind of
other possible measurements so this is
the drug sensitivity data
but for the uh pharmacogenomics data set
you know there is a quite long history
of it already and there are a lot of
data that have been generated you know
uh during the last you know you can see
more than 20 years and from the
beginning so the scale of the data size
was relatively small so you can see that
excess of uh like a 59 you know cell
lines so the drugs can be big you know
so they can be just a lot of different
types of compounds so as time goes by
someone more especially recently so we
so the for the data set you can see that
we have relatively more cancer cell
lines and more drugs that have been
experimented you know together at the
same time
um so i will first give a brief
introduction on a few studies in my
group and i will focus on the work on
denoising the drug sensitivity data set
so one study in my group is about
uh
leveraging the molecular data in drug
discovery actually that was the
topic i was originally planning to
present in detail and then i realized
some of the audience have heard this
talk already and multiple times actually
so that's why i decided to change but i
will mention very briefly what this
study is about and uh
so in this study here so this one is now
involving uh jack discovery data you
know in the analysis
stage we only use exactly us discovery
data you know for the validation purpose
even though it's not perfect but this
can tell a little bit about the results
so he's trying to connect you know
diseases with drugs so what's doing here
is that you know we have the expression
data like for disease samples and also
control symptoms and then just by
comparison between this disease and the
control sample we can get a list of uh
disease differentially expressed disease
so so the genes on the top or on the
bottom will be significantly upregulated
or downregulated
and then we also have uh you know uh uh
the the expression data you know from uh
treated samples and untreated samples
you know four particular drugs
and basically the comparison between
these samples will give us a list of
genes you know that are showing some
differential expression under the drug
treatment
so you can see that you know the also
the the drugs you know on the two ends
of the genes on the two ends will be the
interesting genes because they are kind
of the genes showing differential
changes you know before and after the
drug treatment so the
motivation here is that you know people
believe so if somehow the
the drug you know differential
expression leads the genes they are
having some kind of reversal correlation
with this disease differential
expressions then it could be indicative
that this drug you know may be a useful
you know uh treatment you know uh
candidate for that disease so basically
so drugs that a reverse expression of a
spectrum of the disease may be a
therapeutic agent so under this
motivation you know there have been
efforts for finding ways you know to try
to find this kind of virtual correlation
between this differential expression
list
but intuitively you can see that you
know uh
we need to focus more on the genes on
the two ends right so the upright
significantly upregulated significantly
down regulated so how to select that
kind of cutoffs and how to really raise
those kind of genes in assessing such
kind of reward correlation so those are
the things we need to consider and we
have developed a method based on kind of
statistics you know to assess that's a
reverse relationship so i will skip the
details of the kind of statistics in
this talk but for anyone who's
interested i'm happy to talk about with
you you know after the talk
so this is uh one study we did and
another study we did is that we tried to
uh
have developed some kind of
understanding on the cancer cell lines
especially try to do some kind of
grouping of the cancer cell lines so
remember that what kind of information
we have the cancer cell line so at least
we have the drug sensitivity data which
means that for each cancer cell line
they have the responses you know of the
cancer cell lines to a list of the drugs
so the number of drugs can vary from you
know hundreds you know to uh
it's from tens to a hundred and they
also have the generation you know
measurements for the cancer cell lines
so if we want to group the cancer cell
lines you know we want to combine the
two data uh together so the way for us
to glue the data together is that for
each kind of small cancer cell and group
we try to build this uh bipartite graph
that is showing the gene and the drug
relationship so we saw that we claimed
that it's the gene drug you know
association pattern so we we build this
one through a sparse canonical
correlation analysis between the drug
sensitivity data and the gene expression
data and then for each small
cancer cell of groups they will have
this kind of
gene drug association patterns to
describe it and then we can move the
cancerous cell line you know small
groups into relatively you know larger
groups based on comparing these kind of
patterns or bipartisan groups so by this
kind of grouping so we are able to um
link some uh cancer cell lines of
different diseases together and that
kind of grouping is more rely on you
know potential treatment methods right
so it's based on the common or similar
or gene drug you know uh
association patents
so this work uh was published last year
in uh bioinformatics so that was a
really early attempt for us to try to
combine the drug sensitivity data and
and the expression data together but
through all of these analysis you know
we realized that so the drug sensitivity
data is not really that ideal you know
in
really in terms of quality so like
people are realized that even though you
know um we follow you know almost the
same protocol to do the experiments and
they are working i have the collection
of the same cancer cell lines and the
one they have you know the same
collection of the drugs but the jackson
sensitivity you know data matrices few
you know are produced from different
labs can still be quite different so
there is a consistent issue you know
between data sets and so we we tried to
make some comparisons you know between
data sets from different uh uh groups so
uh some interesting uh observations were
made so like um we found that you know
the cell was a correlation
so of course it's across the same
collection of drugs and for the same
kind of cell line so the that
correlation is most is stronger compared
to the drag right correlation so the
drug writes correlations if you if you
calculate correlation the correlation is
very low it even though you consider the
size of the vector you know try to uh
use some approximation p values in the p
value you know it's not significant at
all so but the another interesting
observation we observed is that the
dragon balls correlation is low but if
we consider the relative relationship
about the dragonbase correlations like
we found that if the the correlation
between drug 1 and drug 2 is high in
data set one compared to the correlation
between drug one and drug three so that
kind of relationship will be mostly
preserved you know between the data set
so basically like if you just make a
very simple you know uh first you know
uh a degree of comparison between
the data sets the consistency is bad but
if you just look carefully about some
kind of structures of the data you can
see some kind of uh interesting you know
relationships you know between the data
sets so this means that you know there
is a hope you know for us you know try
to um
do something with the data sides to
increase you know the the consistency
and to make the data science more useful
uh
in a large-scale way
okay so
with this question in mind
so we the first time that we did is a
method uh
so it's actually uh in this category but
actually there are a lot of efforts you
know for people trying to increase the
consistency you know between the drug
sensitivity data sets like people are
trying to produce uh or that you know or
introduce different ways to summarize
the
drug response curve
and also there are people trying to
standardize the experimental protocol
you know to hope to reduce you know uh
some
a noise is you know as much as possible
you know you introduced you know by
different expert experimental groups
and so the computational effort uh
that literature is relatively thin at
this moment
so uh
a few years ago one work waiting is that
we you know it's it this is really just
a very early attempt you know for us to
see that just simply by using by making
use of the uh fact we have observed the
diet the cell uh the cell white
correlation is kind of stronger compared
to the drug rights correlation what we
can do so
so this this one so basically means that
we want to find some operations so that
i have here a g here can be considered
as some operations we want to apply on
the matrix based on the column wise you
know of structures of the data of the
column you know consistency information
and
what kind of operations we can find that
that can help you know to be moved to
rem to improve the correlation you know
between the rows or between the drugs so
this is not really an objective function
because there is no way for us to
optimize it this is really just trying
to show that it's kind of the ideal you
know we want to achieve but what what we
can really do at this moment is really
just to find some reasonable operations
you know on the matrices you know to
improve the low voice
and in that paper what they did is that
we just tried to borrow the information
between the two data sets and the
things we have observed strong column
like correlations so we are using uh one
data set in a column as a response the
other data set column as a predictor to
do the regression and we are doing the
by changing the response and the
predictor rules you know doing that
regression alternatively you know to uh
to uh correct and also i impuged some
mission values and it worked very very
well but
this method still has some kind of uh
weakness
so firstly is kind of relying on the uh
two data side and the two data effects
must have a decent overlap regarding the
cancer cell lines and also the drugs but
these days so a lot of studies you know
they have
very focused and you know diseases and
they have very focused drugs so we may
not be able to find some kind of
overlapping you know a data set in some
way so we do see uh
a demand of
to
to study uh you know to to get a method
that can be uh applied on individual you
know drug sensitivity you know data side
and there's so so basically it's like
it's just the one data set not crossing
innovate other datasets or borrowing
information from other data sets can
they still you know try to do some way
to reasonably denoise the data and to
improve the consistency you know between
a data set
um
we so if we want to do that we first
need to convince ourselves that there
are some kind of meaningful structures
in the data that can give us the permits
of the hope you know to do reasonable
dimensionality reduction or do some kind
of low rank metrics approximation you
know to to find the uh uh
to denoise the data so
so based on some literary studies you
know and also our own you know
exploration of the data set so we do see
you know some kind of interesting
structures in the data so like for for
example so there are a lot of uh
vertical as a horizontal and vertical
straps in the data so those uh straps
you know
likely correspond to
either broadly or narrowly you know very
active you know uh small molecules for
the broadly
active molecules so so it means that the
drugs are very toxic in some way so it's
kind of killing all of the cancers
and for the uh narrowly you know about
active uh small molecules so this means
that they are they are really friendly
so they are not uh killing anyone and
for some cancer cell lines you know some
kind like cellular calories penicillin
are very sensitive to almost all drugs
you know they just can be killed you
know very easily and the more so so
basically in our study we are not really
very interested in this kind of drugs or
cancer cell life right so they so it's
showing some kind of structure in the
data but that's not the structure of our
interest so we are more interested in
you know the this kind of hot spots so
it's it's presenting that there is a
group of drugs so they are having some
similar you know practice and somehow
you know they are having similar
effectiveness you know on a group of
cancer cell lines
so there are such kind of groups you
know available and also depending on the
size of the group so this kind of
structure you know can introduce
different level of difficulties you know
for being recognized you know in the in
the study
and um
yeah also situations like you know may
have a single drug
and it's a inhibitor for example in
in this example here is an inhibitor for
you know some type of mutation and and
this drug you know uh will make a big
difference you know between cancer cell
lines that have or doesn't or do not
have that mutation and so basically for
the second and the third you know kind
of uh signals in the data sets are the
signals we want to capture but there are
a lot of more other types of signals you
know hidden in the data we don't know
yet but at least you know by studying
you know the drug sensitivity data in
this exploratory
so we know that there is a hope you know
for some uh meaningful structures you
know to be uh recognized so the method
that we consider you know is along the
line of matrix factorization because you
know that is providing a way you know
for for dimension reduction and also for
the uh low rank you know uh
approximation for the matrix so with the
hope to find the structure but the
traditional you know max factorization
method you know uh when we are using
they here we
so there are a lot of troubles for us so
like you know we don't really know what
is the wreck you know before we do the
analysis so but but for that method we
need to require a specification of the
ranks and also the
non-convex you know nature of the
microfactory factorization itself you
know introduce a lot of you know
challenges for us so
uh
what we we do with this is that we we
try to explore the use of a version of
deep matrix factorization to see that
the deep matrix factorization wider is
kind of uh helping us to
recover some tricky
structures that have been missed you
know by um classical or traditional
electric micro spectralization methods
so this is the um uh brief you know
procedure here but i just want to
emphasize a few things so the the one
thing here you know so this that can be
considered the matrix you want to
recover so you are representing it as
the product of multiple matrix so the
difference you know between the deep
matrix factorization and the traditional
matrix factorization is about the kind
of a dimension here so the original
matrix is of dimension and by p
and in traditional matrix factorization
method so the dimension you know for m1
m2 you know w1 or w2 here they will be
less than the minimum of an mp
but in this matrix factorization they
don't have any constraint on what the
value of w1 and w2 can be so basically w
and that v2 can be larger than p
then immediately this becomes
a non-identifiable problem right so we
have been you know uh introducing uh
you know previously in a large search
space basically to for this kind of
bitmatrix factorization purpose
but the
optimization part can be done through
this agreed and decent method
and then we also introduce a residual
thresholding like if there are some kind
of operators you know after this kind of
low rank you know approximation if those
kind of other layers are showing some
meaningful particle structures we want
we want item back okay so i i want to
give some intuitive understanding on
this deep mattress factorization so we
are actually ourselves still in the
process of understanding the deep
microspectralization better but
basically you know we think that
compared to traditional matter
factorization so this deep micro
factorization is uh
is is making the search space much much
louder than the traditional one so the
traditional one to make the problem
identifiable they have to narrow down
the subspace and they are trying to find
the optimal solution in the restricted
you know space as much as possible for
this for this deep matrix factorization
here so the surface phase is large it's
not an identifiable problem at all but
you know the the optimization procedure
or the regulation introduced here is to
make the search pass you know is limited
so basically means that we are finding a
sub-optimal solution in a very large
subspace
so if the
matrix itself is very complicated having
a lot of tricky and hidden structures so
basically this deep matrix factorization
method is having a better hope you know
to recover that
so that's is the intuitive
understanding about this method here and
of course you know just like other
learning methods you know it's very
scalable
and also
we found that you know we don't really
have to uh decide the ranks you know of
the low rank approximation and and also
the result is pretty uh stable
so
okay so this is showing that how we can
decide where to stop so in deep learning
methods early stopping is very critical
and for us we are able to check that
when there is kind of a big departure
between the training and the testing
arrows you know that means that's the
perfect stop so if we stop any places
around here you know we will be doing
good okay i don't have much time here so
let me just go to some kind of re so
simulation results we make comparison
between like robust pca
and this is our deep matrix
factorization and this is just a
traditional matrix factorization and
this is the
original structure so you can see that
for for some kind of you know standard
structures so this micro factorization
is working very similarly with robust
pca but you know like for situations
like this when they have two kind of
overlapping blocks so somehow the robust
pca failed and the magic factorization
you know it's not powerful at all
and
so let me uh so and then for the real
data status so we uh worked on these
five data sets
because of their size and then you can
see it roughly so this is one data set
and this is another so x-axis you
representing one data set y-axis is
representing the other data set and we
want to see that the correspondence or
the consistency between the data sets
and this is the original one this is the
correction one so if the you'll see you
know the that the pattern is along the
diagonal line that means the consistency
is better
so roughly we can see that after the
correction so this is towarding mode you
know to this kind of a diagonal line so
this shows some level of consistency and
this is a particular example for single
drug and the purple points is before the
deep matrix factorization correction and
there are the yellow points are after so
you can also see that for individual
drugs you know between different data
sets after the correction the
correspondence also become better
okay so
yeah this is just showing you know uh uh
effects of a drag on on this mutated or
non-mutated cell cell lines it's just
after the correction we can see that we
can have a better separation between the
mutated uh mutated and non-rotated you
know cell lines so so these are these
are some kind of examples to show the
method which is working but as i have
mentioned that we are still in the
process of exploring the deep matrix
factorization for his property and also
his application in denoising last data
sets
thank you
oh i want to thank my students for their
contribution for all of this work so the
deep mattress background edition
basically have been done by tao muhfu
and the yao doom you know one from balsa
and the other from ecx
questions yeah so
some questions here
uh thanks so it's actually about the the
first story that you didn't go too deep
because you already explained it before
but i didn't know it uh so i was
wondering how do you decompose the the
treatments that the patients could have
when you do the comparisons with the
cell lines and the drug different drugs
but patients sometimes already are
taking drugs that
can be different between patients i was
wondering that how that's
that one hadn't been
you know incorporated yet but clearly
that's something you know
that will introduce a better resolution
of the data yeah so like if we really
want to go to the personal lives you
know medicine direction yes yeah but the
current you know our data set here is so
what we have is really that's the cancer
cell lines and the drugs yeah
so the individual patient effects
wouldn't really consider okay but that's
a great point thank you
um
so maybe a little bit related to that um
yeah because you know the cell lines are
like
individual entities and patients we have
a more complex tissue so are you also
like
working on organoids or something that
could resemble better you know like a
structure of the patient so that you can
also access successfully the drug and
things like that
yeah if we have you know uh satisfying
data and
so that's something we want to
incorporate like so hopefully that can
uh give us some kind of guidance in
terms of the dimensionality reduction
yeah so that that that will be related
to like you know one way are you
introducing or working on the d matrix
factorization uh method so whether we
can modify the objective function
internally to reflect such kind of you
know additional prior information
about yeah
thank you
more
questions
i knew
i mean following up on this
question about you know the cell lines
and other elements i was just wondering
uh one element of the rationale and this
matching of transcription signatures
which is what you really ultimately want
to achieve right
is that the differential expressions
patterns you find between cases and
controls
reflect what you would like to revert
and i was wondering whether so you mean
the first one right there yeah the
motivation slides where you really start
at the beginning i was wondering to what
extent your model
like the cleaning also
tackles the fundamental challenge here
and one of them is that obviously
differential expression between case and
control also reflects you know many of
the consequences downstream of the
disease you know that are not causative
and that you don't want to treat
you know immune system responses
whatever whatever is that something that
you're also implicitly hoping to adjust
using your deep nmf
or is it really more technical variation
and if not is that problem not also
something to consider so so the deep
mitral factorization that method is
separate from this because this one here
you can see it's really just expression
and for the deep micro factorization
approach i
introduced we we are just exploring its
application in the drug sensitivity data
so it's yeah
different applications
but the points you uh discussed here i i
see that like you know so like
to
a size reverse correlation is really
just the first step right it can just
give a very rough match between drugs
and the disease but the next step you
know what other drugs will be really
attracting you know the the doctor's you
know attention of the the pharmaco you
know our company's attention what to do
for the experiments then they have to do
more work further you know throughout
the direction you have just described
yeah so no thanks
um
and then we can go for a hike right so
we can carry